the kansas city chiefs have to be very
happy to hear this conversation about
the jaguars because the last thing
anyone there has to worry about is
anyone wanting out is any type of
dysfunction any type of tanking they
already got patrick mahomes he signed
for 12 more years and now andy reid and
brett veach peter they get the the
fruits of their labor and of finding and
trusting in themselves on patrick
mahomes new contracts for them looks
like stability for the chiefs for a long
time to come
well mike i remember being around the
chiefs a lot last year in january and
february and i got the distinct
impression
that there may be an expiration date on
andy reid three four years down the road
maybe
um but here he is he's 62 years old he's
been totally rejuvenated uh by working
with patrick mahomes he loves his
coaching staff he loves this team
and i think he just felt i've got a
general manager who uh basically
completes my sentences
i really like the situation we're in
i believe there's a good chance he'll
fulfill the six years you never know
but at the age of 62 i think he saw
himself coaching
you know at least
uh
you know the next five six years so that
he can have the benefit of working with
patrick mahomes and again you cannot
emphasize enough
how much he is uh at peace
uh not only with the city and with the
job but also with his general manager he
and brett veach veach came in
during the 2016 college football season
and basically told andy reid
you know i got a guy for you and in his
spare time he would watch patrick
mahomes
and at the same time
veach was working
uh
you know
working his friends in the league and
trying to figure out who we gonna trade
with to get up to get patrick mahomes so
they moved up i think 17 spots and we're
able to move up and get mahomes and the
rest is history yeah it's amazing i i
wouldn't expect a guy like andy reid to
want to walk away anytime soon man you
got to ride this train right now
what
i mean you have a chance to go i mean
and really andy reid went to from one
year going to oh man
gosh this is one of the more you know
underrated great coaches of our time he
can't win the big game to now he won the
big game and is one of the most stunning
fashions we've ever seen and he's got
this great quarterback and you're going
uh oh watch out kansas city might let it
fly now they might they might win for it
in the next six i mean we're i don't
think any of us would sit here and go oh
my gosh if if kansas city won three or
more
you know three more super bowls in the
next six years i wouldn't be shocked so
mahomes is i'm sure made andy reid feel
younger the pressure's off the situation
we know andy was a you know
fun-loving good guy who likes the grind
of it and to what peter and mike you
said as well like brett veach is the
perfect compliment i mean hey ever since
brett's beach has been there in kansas
city he has found way to get talent and
they've had talent on the roster and
then yeah the vision to make the move
for patrick mahomes and i'd just like to
remind everybody before patrick mahomes
got there they were the number two seed
in the afc playoffs they had already
built the damn good team and they looked
at it and said damn we need just a
quarterback that can make a difference
and that's where they made an aggressive
move got my home so what peter is saying
and it's changed their organization so
you can't say enough about the coach the
the ability to
evaluate players and what they put
together there in kansas city is is
pretty damn special
and yeah a lot bigger
one go ahead
mike let me just say one other thing
you know
life
often times when you get to be in your
60s
and i speak from experience on that
life becomes a series of things that you
can choose to do
if you enjoy doing them why do i do the
job i do right now because i really
still love it okay and i'll give you an
andy reed example of that here's a 61
year old football coach
and i asked him in the dead week last
week between the championship game and
the super bowl if i could ride to work
one morning with him and just talk to
him i had done it with sean mcvay the
previous year doug peterson the year
before that and i write the column the
week before the super bowl hey here's
the mindset of one of the coaches in the
super bowl so andy reid tells me i'll
pick you up at your hotel at 3 15
a.m what i said oh my god well okay all
right i'll i'll be ready
and i got down at three about 3 10 3 11.
and there's andy reid he's sitting in
the driveway of the hotel waiting for me
i said when did you get there he goes oh
about three four minutes ago
so let's say andy reid got there at 307
i mean
here's a guy who just can't wait to get
to work
and and so you wonder geez you know
you're maybe lean you know starting to
get into the time when people think it's
your golden years
for andy reid he wants to spend his
golden years with patrick mahomes
yeah when you finally have a quarterback
who makes you look good just by showing
up who can go out there and clean up
your messes on the fly without a
complaint the play you called didn't
work well the quarterback you have will
abandon that play come up with something
on the fly run left run white right uh
throw it behind his back if he has to
and and you look like the genius
although everybody kind of knows it's
mahomes but that's the thing they've
already done the hard work they drafted
him
they signed him
they have him for 12 more years now is
the part where you just sit back and
enjoy the spoils chris of having one of
the best quarterbacks of all time and
seeing how many super bowls he can
deliver that's right i mean this is a
dream come true for a mad scientist like
andy reid i mean it is like hey you go
here you go here you go here just
everybody go deep this guy will throw it
to you let alone
you know
what kind of and peter could probably
speak to this better than anybody and
honestly peter i want to hear you talk
about this after
the the energy my homes can bring to a
building on every day right just that
the cool calm collect humbleness but yet
we see the videos out at practice he's
always energetic he's competing throwing
balls in a garbage can paying tribute to
the black panther yesterday uh the actor
who passed away i mean he's just
he's he's a breath of fresh air and i
would think as a head coach and
especially as an offensive head coach
who's very into the quarterback position
it just probably makes everything in the
building life easier on a daily basis
let alone you know what he does on the
field and i'm sure andy reid has had
this a little bit he i would think it
almost reminds him of brett favre where
man every day i came in brett favre is a
crazy guy in green bay he loves throwing
lasers all over the field and the whole
team just like gravitates toward that i
would think there's some magic there you
tell me if i'm wrong uh peter about uh
mahomes yeah
chris i think you're right but there's
one other thing that i think it you know
even takes this to the next level beyond
farve and that is and i'll give you an
example i'll tell you when andy reid
knew
absolutely for sure that he had his
quarterback for the next 15 years or
however however long he coaches him
in 2018
the kansas city chiefs had to fire
kareem hunt because they felt he had
been dishonest with the organization
about an off-season event involving
abuse of a woman
and so they fired him on a friday
afternoon
and on saturday they had to fly to
oakland for a game but on saturday
morning
patrick mahomes who at the time
was younger than 49 of the 53 players
are the other 52 players rather on the
roster patrick mahomes asked andy reid
can i talk to the team
can i just have some time
and they had a players only meeting no
coaches andy reid to this day doesn't
know for sure what mahomes said to him
but he granted patrick the time with the
team probably only two or three minutes
and in that time mahomes said we all
love kareem hun everybody here in this
room regardless of what happened he's
always going to be a friend of ours and
all this but he said we cannot let this
derail our season
we can't let this be a ruinous turning
point for this team
and he all the players walked out of the
room that is when andy reid knew he not
only had patrick mahomes the kind of
loose player great practice player all
that stuff and great player in games he
also had the leader of the team when 48
guys on the team were younger than he
was
and see that's the older rather no sorry
you don't know and you never will know
when you're scouting players coming into
the nfl whether it's mitchell trubisky
patrick mahomes desean watson deshaun
kaiser was part of that group in 2017.
there was another one or two i just
remember there was this cluster of
quarterbacks where no one really quite
knew what was going to happen and we
never know because one of the reasons we
don't know
we don't know whether or not a guy has
that stuff that inherent makeup to be
able to take over our locker room the
way that patrick mahomes can we didn't
know it until he did it and that's why
peter i i think andy reid had that that
epiphany when you see the guy do it
that's when you realize he's got it and
all the time and effort they spend
scouting and watching film and talking
to these guys in a hotel room in
indianapolis you don't know that until
it actually happens
no you don't you're right that was sorry
go ahead go ahead peter
i was just gonna say that really was the
key thing and that happened a year and a
half after they drafted him mike
mike the other thing i just think is
amazing about mahomes that we just got
to talk about since we're on it too just
just there you know again it just
like
what do i want to say unflappable
inflammable how the hell what's that
word there that you really are
it's unflappable unflapping and
inflammable okay and inflammable but
he's unflappable he's the most
unflappable quarterback i've ever seen
in my life and he's only going into year
four of his career i mean it's insane
and i'll go back to something that you
know my dad told me that the tennessee
titan coaches told him last year at the
afc championship game hey you guys gonna
blitz my homes nope nope we're not gonna
we you can't fluster my homes we've
we've we've seen him for three years now
he's nobody flusters him and i mean if
you just think about it i think that's
the most amazing thing to me about the
guy hey the talent is through the roof
and we know that
you know peter talks about you know
leadership and being humble and all
that's amazing too i'm just amazed that
no matter what the situation hey it's a
bad half in the afc championship game
against the patriots oh he comes out
zing zing zing oh whoa it's a game oh
new england's taking control of the game
whoa kansas city has 40 seconds to go
down and kick a field goal no problem
zing okay now this year in the afc
playoffs the super bowl i mean what the
hell that was it's just unbelievable
i've never seen a kid come into the
league and just be like oh hey it's i'm
in the backyard or i'm at the school
yard again playing ball and just
dominating no big deal
yeah i agree and it gives the team
confidence gives him confidence chris
something you've said time and again
getting that first one so early
it it gives him that faith even though
they had to come from behind double
digits every single game along the way
to get there in the postseason
it gives him that confidence that he can
just keep doing it and doing it and
doing it peter and that's why we've got
guys on that on that roster and i if i'm
andy reid i don't like this talking
about six or seven championships by the
time it's all said and done
yeah andy does not like that at all
because he remembers the last time when
uh when that happened and everybody said
in philadelphia they had a dream team
right and they stunk
and uh vince young and namdi asamwa and
everything and just it just didn't work
so
yeah
you know i think bill belichick and i'm
going to absolutely massacre some cliche
that he has that you know it's a lot
better to do than to say
um tom brady says that now and i don't
know what what it is but you get the pen
you get the message i think reed would
rather have them do it but
that's really the way that's the feeling
internally on that team
and i think the key for andy reid now
and the challenge for him and the chiefs
going forward and they're about to get
their super bowl rings they teased it
last night on twitter and that's going
to dust off those good feelings they had
back in february you kind of like to put
that all to bed you know belichick's big
on that whatever happened last year
you close that book you put it on the
shelf and you forget about it until you
retire
that's going to be the challenge for the
chiefs now how do you handle the fact
that that that book's still open
you're not going to close until you get
that ring you're getting that ring at
nine days eight days seven days before
you start your title defense belichick's
always big on that get the trip to the
white house out of the way get the rings
distributed we're forgetting about last
year because last year doesn't matter at
all
and look i with patrick mahomes
everything's possible but that's the
next challenge can they forget about
last year and focus on this year peter
i mean
what i saw when i saw them for a couple
of days out in kansas city the answer is
yes and look they're infusing their team
with a superb young player clyde edwards
hilaire
that uh
you know who who i think is going to
bring some new energy to this team and
bring some new excitement to this team
much like in my opinion kareem hunt did
in 2017
when he came in as uh whatever the 85th
pick in the draft and and won the
rushing title so i think there's going
to be some newness there's going to be a
little bit of newness
on defense too
more speed at linebacker so i you know
they're infusing this team with
some youth at a time when every team has
to
yeah they've done a great job of staying
ahead of the curve they do have young
talent you're right about that they got
a good offensive line they got a good
defensive line hey they got guys that
weren't a part of that super bowl run
last year because the injuries are going
to be back in the fold this year that
you can almost look at and go like
that's a free agent you know to have
they're going to have okafor back on the
end of the defensive line you know
breeland speaks he'll be back another
good defensive end defensive tackle type
juan thornhill they're starting safety
he was a rookie last year he wasn't a
part of it you know sammy watkins they
get him to stay healthy so
mike i hear you it's odd to be getting
the rings right now because you got you
got to think about this there's a number
of guys that are going to be in that
locker room that they weren't there last
year so you know close the yearbook it
is it's very weird that you're going to
be diving back into last year's thoughts
this early you know into the next
following season uh but i do think this
is a group that can handle that i do
think they want to be great and i think
what we're all saying is
we think at least and you guys correct
me i think this is the jump ball point
you know i think you might some people
might go wait are they gonna still be
motivated or is this gonna take the
pressure off and they're gonna run with
it and i'm one of those i think the
pressure's off and on mahomes andy reed
and everything and i feel like they're
the type of group that's gonna just
relish kind of having the bullseye on
their back and just letting it fly
you know part of the reality of giving
out the rings this week too you're going
to have some bottom of the roster guys
who are going to get a super bowl ring
one day and maybe a pink slime a couple
of days later
it's weird you guys are if new guys are
making the team old guys are going to be
gone and it's going to be kind of a
strange week for some of those
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports